You know,
the book is not played out,
the idea of what a book can be is not
played out in its form as it is with
paper and covers and um,
and there are things that can be,
that digital will never touch and that's
one of the things I wanted to do with
this and comparing it to a cassette
tape,
the old fashioned way of making a mix
which,
you know,
I love burning cds too,
but there is something far more
passionate and hands on and hard work
about making a mix tape on a cassette.
A,
it's too easy to revise with a CD and
today's technology makes it too easy to,
to,
to change immediately.
Uh,
you can cover your mistakes quicker.
I,
th,
I think,
uh,
I think it allows you to have the sheen
of perfection around yourself.
Uh,
and with a old fashioned book or an old
fashioned cassette tape,
you can actually see all the flaws and
imperfections and the bad choices.
Uh,
and I think there's something we lose
with technology when you talk about bad
choices
like costs $300,
number one,
I don't think anything that costs $300
can be called egalitarian.
You know,
how much of the world can afford a $300
reading device,
a one percent of one percent of one
percent that automatically qualifies for
economically elite status.
But what we're,
what's really going on here,
the reading public doesn't really know
about all they're concerned about and
all their defending is they're reading
convenience,
which I completely understand whether
it's because of physical disability or
because of personal preference or just
the newness of it,
why they love a digital book,
but they don't understand the economic
corporate pressures going on in the
publishing world and what's going to
happen.
And this is going to happen on the
Internet to,
uh,
we liked to pretend that the internet is
free.
Uh,
you know,
we like to pretend it's an opensource
culture.
But as culture changes,
as corporate,
old corporate models of distributing
information are changing,
you know,
I don't know why people assume that
corporations aren't going to take over
this medium as well because they can.
And,
and,
uh,
so what's happening in the book world
digital books is that these ebook
companies,
you know,
Amazon,
Barnes and noble,
others that are rising a,
they just don't seek to publish books.
They're going to end up seeking the
books to be chosen to be published.
So,
uh,
this economic model,
the way it's set up now is going to
favor a certain kind of book a and
publishers and being economically
motivated companies are only going to be
publishing those kinds of books and the
divide between pop culture,
pop writing and literary writing.
Is this going to increase and increase
and increase?
And it's going to make it harder and
harder and harder for first time writers
to get published in any form whatsoever
where they'll get attention,
who can find you,
uh,
who,
who's going to find anybody.
Uh,
nobody's really arisen out of the
Internet to become a major voice.
Uh,
they always end up getting a book
published and then the book makes them a
major voice,
but nobody has.
I mean,
uh,
I'm trying to think,
you know,
I'm not Internet averse at all.
I'm doing this,
uh,
I mean I love the Internet,
but the fact is,
is that it's a giant,
giant,
unfiltered library,
which,
which has the strength and beauty,
but it's impossible to find people.
And you what we ended up doing anyways,
I go to about five sites,
uh,
you know,
and I think most people probably do the
same thing.
You create this little small town inside
the Internet and we end up in all of
these little tiny separate communities.
Uh,
Joan Jett and interview with Joan Jett,
she said about the music industry.
She said the thing that's missing now is
anticipation.
They see said that nobody gets in a big
line outside of tower records anymore,
waiting for that new stones album to
drop.
And nobody stands in line outside or a
record store waiting to buy the tickets
for the WHO concert.
Uh,
there's a real lack of community on the,
uh,
you know,
in the Internet experience when it comes
to art and you can't tell me and it's
not true that communicating strictly
through the Internet forums community
and the way that being together does a,
you're missing all but one sense.
You don't smell people,
you don't really hear him,
you don't see him.
Uh,
and we're animals.
We're creatures of senses and the
Internet deprives you of many of those.
And,
and,
uh,
so,
I,
I know there's new art coming based on
this technology and some of it's
happening and it's exciting and
interesting,
but there's nothing wrong with the old
art.
And I always worry and you see it with
certain Internet folks,
the way in which they're completely
willing to jettison their past and the
pursuit of something new.
And that's what I'm worried about.